اتهمت دمشق ما سمتها التنظيمات الارهابيه
بالوقوف وراء قصف الكليه الحربيه في حمص
الذي اوقع اكثر من 300 بين قتيل وجريح من
جانبه اعلن الدفاع المدني بريف ادلب سقوط
عشرات القتل والجرحى في قصف للنظام السوري
يتزامن هذا مع اسقاط الجيش الامريكي مسيره
تركيه في سوريا وتاكيد موسكو تعاونها مع
دمشق لمكافحه ما سمته
الارهاب
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم كان ذاك خبر حلقتنا ولنا في
نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات ما هي الابعاد الامنيه
والاستراتيجيه لهذه الحوادث المتزامنه في
سوريا وعلى اي نحو يمكن ان نفهم مواقف
الاطراف الفاعله في سوريا على ضوء هذه
الحوادث كيف ستنعكس هذه التطورات على
المشهد في الداخل السوري وما مدى امكانيه
تحولها الى دوره جديده من العنف بين
مكونات هذا المشهد وما التاثير الذي يمكن
ان تتركه هذه الاحداث على مواقف وحسابات
الاطراف الاقليميه والدوليه المعنيه
بسوريا في ضوء تاكيد موسكو استعدادها
للانخراط بقوه الى جانب
[موسيقى]
دمشق
احداث عاصفه عاشتها اجزاء مختلفه من سوريا
بصوره متزامنه يوم الخميس واستمرت بعض
تداعياتها الجمعه بينما يرى كثيرون ان
تاثيرها سيمتد لاكثر من ذلك بكثير فقد
اتهمت دمشق التي بدات يوم الجمعه تشيع نحو
90 شخصا سقطوا في قصف على حفل تخريج لضباط
الكليه الحربيه في حمص اتهمت ما سمتها
التنظيمات الارهابيه بالوقوف وراء الهجوم
الذي وقع الخميس وادى ايضا الى اصابه اكثر
من 200
جريح تحمل دمشق المعارضه السوريه مسؤوليه
هجوم حمص تبيعه وعلى نحو عاجل قصف صاروخي
ومدفعي على مناطق في ريفي ادلب وحلب اوقع
العشرات بين قتيل وجريح وشنه بحسب الدفاع
المدني في شمال غرب سوريا جيش النظام
والقوات
الروسيه وفي موسكو التي دانت هجوم حمص
ووصفته بالارهابي واعربت عن توقعها معاقبه
المسؤولين عنه اكد الكريملين في بيان ان
روسيا تعتزم مواصله العمل عن كسب مع شركاء
السوريين فيما سماه مكافحه جميع اشكال
الارهاب وبعيدا عن هجوم حمص وما ترتب عليه
اعلنت واشنطن اسقاط مسيره تركيه في سوريا
فيما اعتبرته وزاره الدفاع الامريكيه
البنتاجون امرا مؤسفا المتحدث باسم
البنتاجون اكد عقب الحادث ان وزيري الدفاع
الامريكي والتركي بحثا في اتصال هاتفي
التنسيق المشترك بين بلديهما للحيلوله دون
تعرض القوات الامريكيه لاي
تهديد
[موسيقى]
لمناقشه هذا الموضوع ينضم الينا من غازي
عنتاب الدكتور محمد سالم مدير وحده
الدراسات في مركز ابعاد للدراسات
الاستراتيجيه من واشنطن معنا السفير جيمز
جيفري المبعوث الامريكي السابق الى سوريا
ومن موسكو اندريه اونت كوف الكاتب والمحلل
السياسي مرحبا بكم جميعا دكتور محمد سالم
سنبدا معك يعني بعد مرور نحو 24 ساعه على
وقوع الهجوم على الاكاديميه العسكريه في
حمص كيف قرات الا ابعاد والاهداف من وراء
هذا الهجوم بالهدف الذي جرى قصفه
بالمنطقه وبتوقيت
ايضا ا تحيه لكم ومشاهدي الكرام وللضيوف
الكرام وشكرا على الاستضافه يعني المنطقه
محصنه جدا ومنطقه امنيه شديده التحصين
فيها الكثير من القطعات التابعه للنظام
وبالتالي يصعب حقيقه
حصول استهداف خارجي ومن غير المعروف حتى
الان كيفيه حدوث مثل هذا التفجير هل حدث
هذا التفجير من خلال انتحاري من خلال
مفخخه هناك حديث عن طائرات مسيره ويبدو
انه هذا يرجحه البعض لكن لا توجد ادله
كافيه
ل تاكيد مثل مثل هذا الخبر لكن بكل
الاحوال رده فعل الاعلام الخاص او التابع
الرديف سواء الرسمي او الرديف للنظام في
ظل وجود مؤسسه امنيه معروفه بمركزها
الشديده وتانيها في الرد يعني سابقا كان
عندما يحصل مثلا هجوم اسرائيلي نحن نعلم
ردود فعل الحكومه السوريه تكون بطيئه قد
يطول الامر يومين حتى ا تصدر بيان لكن هنا
رد الفعل الاعلامي والتحشيد الاعلامي
باتجاه المعارضه وكان هناك يعني معرفه
ربما مسبقه وهذا ما يقوله بعض المحللين
واعتقد انه يعني افتراض منطقي يضاف الى
ذلك رده الفعل العسكري
الهجوميه
والتحشيد السريعه التي بدات بها قوات
النظام على محافظه ادلب تحديدا في ظل ظروف
حاليه يعاني منها النظام بشكل كبير من
ناحيه وجود مشاكل داخليه بدات تظهر هو
دائما النظام كان يعتمد فكره انه لا صوت
يعلو فوق صوت المعركه وهناك تهديد خارجي
يهددنا كمو والين وهذا حقيقه كان يوحد
الموالين تحته لكن بوجود مشاكل اقتصاديه
كبيره وازدياد هذه المشاكل وعدم قدره
النظام على الايفاء بوعوده كان دائما
النظام يقول انه خلصت انتهت المعارك
وبالتالي هناك فرصه الان لاستعاده الحياه
الطبيعيه لكن للاسف الوضع الاقتصادي
السر يعني حتى لان لانه لا معطيات كافيه
حول الجهه التي تقف وراء هذا الهجوم ولكن
بغض النظر عن الجهه باعتقادك وبحسب تحليلك
ما هي الاهداف من
وراءه
هو انا هذا ما احاول ان اقراه من ناحيه
انه من المستفيد بشكل اكبر الذي يبدو لي
انه النظام وايران يحاولون الاستفاده بشكل
كبير واستفادوا بشكل كبير مما حصل من خلال
تحشيد
الموالين من خلال القول انه هناك تهديدات
خارجيه جديده وانه هناك حرب على الارهاب
وايضا على هذا على المستوى الداخلي ومستوى
الحاضنه الشعبيه المواليه للنظام وعلى
المستوى الخارجي ايضا
دور يعني كيف ستفيد النظام واير من
استهداف المؤسسه التي تقاتل الى جانبهم
ومعهم هو في النهايه ليس استهدافا يعني
محوريا يمكن ان يؤدي الى ضرر كبير في هذه
المؤسسه انما هو استهداف نوعي كمن يحاول
ان يعني دعنا
نقل
يعني يقوم بجراحه صغيره بهدف انعاش الجسم
بشكل كامل لا لست مع نظريه المؤامره ولا
يوجد دلائل كافيه على هذا الامر لكن حتى
الان لا توجد دلائل كافيه على اي احد
مستفيد اخر هناك بعض التحليلات التي يعني
انا اقتنع بها من ناحيه انه كان هناك تورط
لايران مثلا سابقا في العراق في موضوع قصف
المراقد الشيعيه بهدف تحشيد الطائفه
الشيعيه وزياده وزياده تسعير الطائفيه
لانه مفيد لمشروعها هذا ايضا مناسب هنا
هذا التحليل اعتقد انه في ذات السياق يمكن
ان ان يقرا بهذا الشكل لكن لا توجد اطراف
خارجيه في المقابل قادره او راغبه بمثل
هذا العمل يعني المعارضه السوريه التي تم
اتهامها سريعا من قبل نظام الاسد هي غير
قادره على مثل هذا الموضوع تقنيا القيام
بسواء ارسال طائرات مسيره لهذه المسافه او
اختراق امني داخل النظام بهذه القدره
اندري اتيكو روسيا سارعت للقول انها تقف
الى جانب دمشق في هذه المعركه ضد ما تسميه
الارهاب ماذا عن القراءه الروسيه لما حدث
وللاهل نحن نرى ان من تعرض لهذا الهجوم هم
بالاساس كما تفضلت سابقا الموالين لسلطات
السوريه فمن الواضح ان مكافحه ضد
المجموعات الارهابيه في سوريا لم تنتهي
بعد توجد هناك مجموعات الارهابيه معترفه
بهذا الشكل دوليا هيئه تحرير الشام داعش
وغيرها من المنظمات فلذلك
يعني المشكله حتى بعيدا عن هذا الحدث
المشكله بري شخصي هي ان سوريا اعدم انهاء
للازمه السوريه وتواجد بهذه الكثافه
اللاعبين الخارجيين وبالقوه بالقوات في
الاراض السوريه يؤدي الى ان الازمه
السوريه لا يعني سوريا
ت سيد اندري قبل ان نتوسع الى الى هذا الى
هذا البعد من الحوار انت قلت والنظام
اصلا اتهم من يسميهم المجموعات الارهابيه
في اشاره الى فصائل المعارضه ولكن ضيفنا
من غازي عنتاب يقول لك لا توجد اصلا اطراف
بين هؤلاء قادره او راغبه في هذا في هذا
النوع من الاستهداف لا تمتلك هذه
القدرات انا لا يمكن ان اوافق مع حز رويا
بسبب استعمال المسيرات كانت قبل فتره
طويله
ضد الجيش السوري ضد الاماكن السوريه والى
ما
هنالك يعني حتى روسيا قبل سنوات قد نشرت
في بعض المعارض المسعرات التي او ما ت بق
من المسيرات التي اسقطت من قبل القوات
الروسيه من قبل القوات
السوريه موق سيد اندري
اونو باعتراف جميع المحللين والمراقبين
العسكريين يقولون ان المنطقه الفاصله بين
الهدف الذي جرى قصفه ومناطق المعارضه هي
اكثر من 100 كومتر ولا
توجد لدى هذه الفصائل مثل هكذا اسلحه يمكن
ان تخرج من مناطقها او مسيرات يمكن ان
تخرج من مناطقها وتقصف هذه القاعده
العسكريه انا لا اعتقد ذلك بسبب ان لدى كل
فصيله بما في ذلك فصيله الارهابيه توجد
لديها دوله او دول التي تدعمها فلا توجد
بال الاساس هناك المجموعات الارهابيه
المنفض فلذلك
التي تريد ان لفصائل المعارضه ان تقوم
بمثل هكذا
هجمات انا ربما يمكن ان اجيب على سؤالك
بشكل غير المباشر وفقا لما نراه من
العمليه العسكريه الروسيه في اوكرانيا
فهناك محاولات لفرض مزيد ومزيد من من
المشاكل على روسيا سواء كان في ناغورنو
كارباخ او في سوريا من جديد اقول سوريا
الازمه السوريه عدم وجودها لهذه الازمه
يؤدي الى ان سوريا اصبحت مكانا للاسف جيدا
ان صح التعبير لارسال مختلف الرسائل
لتصفيه الحسابات بين الول المختلفه بما في
ذلك توجد هناك روسيا توجد هناك القوات
الروسيه توجد هناك تركيا توجد هناك
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه ف بطبيعه
الحال في دوء التواتر في العلاقات بين
الدول المذكوره فعن لا سب بان في نهايه
المطاف ما نشاهده هي اما الرساله اي طبعا
قبل كل شيء الى روسيا والى سوريا او تصفيه
الحسابات طيب جيمز جيفري السفير جيمز جفري
من واشنطن بالتزامن مع
هذا الحدث في حمص كان هناك اسقاط من جانب
الولايات المتحده لمسيره تركيا في في مكان
اخر في الشمال الشرقي اي ل سوريا باعتقادك
ما خطوره هذا الامر والاحتمالات التي يفتح
عليها اولا شكرا
لاستضافته ان اي حادث من هذه الحوادث بين
تركيا والولايات المتحده بالتاكيد امر
خطير لاننا نتعاون حول مجالات كثيره ف في
سياره سوريا ضد ايران وايضا ما تتعلق ب
وايضا في الوز واوكرانيا
ومساله انضمام السويد الى النيتو ولكن هذا
الامر يعكس اولا ان هناك بيكي كا اي حزب
العمال الكردستاني يريد تصعيد العمل بدا
يصعد العمل في تركيا وقد اعترف
ذلك هذه القوات واثرت حتى هاجموا مقر
الشرطه في هناك وبالتالي فهذا ادى الى
هجمات تركيه ضد
عناصر بيكي كا وعناصر وحدات حمايه الشعب
الكرديه وان التنسيق الولايات المتحده
وتركيا انخفض وشعرت القوات الامريكيه انهم
يشعرون بخطر وذلك اسقطوا هذه المسيره ولكن
رغم ذلك فهناك مسؤولون كبار من امريكا
وتركيا يعملون بشكل كبير لاعاده بناء
الثقه ونسيان هذه الحادثه والتاكد من عدم
تكرارها سي السفي سيد السفير نحن الان
امام عمليه
عسكريه متواصله ينفذها الجيش التركي ضد
قوات سوريا ديمقراطيه في تلك المنطقه
وبالتالي بوجود هذا الامر ما خطوره ان
يتكرر ما حدث بالامس وما الاحتمالات التي
يمكن ان يفتحها
عليها انا متاكد الى حد كبير بان القوات
العسكريه التركيه والاستخبارات التركيه
سيكون اكثر حذرا في العمل وال تعامل مع
القوات الامريكيه ولكن صحيح ان الضربات
الجويه التركيه مستمره ومعدلات اكثر مما
شهدناها في السنوات ال5 الماضيه ضد قوات
حمايه الشعب الكرديه ولكن الذي يجب
متابعته هل هناك سيك هناك اقتحامات ارضيه
وهذا سيؤثر يؤثر على العلاقات التركيه
الامريكيه علىق في
سوريا وقد يؤدي الى كسر كبير في كل
العلاقات بين البلدين وبشك على التعاون
الكب العام الذي يقومون به يقوم به
البلدان في سوريا محمد سالم تزامن كل هذه
الاحداث مع بعضها البعض
زياده على ذلك الان التصعيد الذي يقوم به
النظام والقوات الروسيه ضد مناطق المعارضه
في ادلب والمستمر منذ الامس على ماذا يفتح
بالنسبه للشمال السوري كله وعلى الازمه
السوريه
عموما
للاسف هذا يمكن ان يفتح الباب مجددا بعد
حصول تهدئه طويله الامد يعني نحن تقريبا
منذ اتفاق اذار بين الرئيسين اردوغان
وبوتين كان هناك تهدئه نسبيه ا هذا
الاتفاق حصل طبعا بال 2020 والى الان ربما
افضل فتره وصلت لها وصل لها الشمال السوري
من ناحيه انه ثبتت خطوط التماس بالاضافه
الى الهدوء النسبي وخاصه في السنه الاخيره
بعد ان يعني تورطت روسيا في اوكرانيا
واصبح بالتالي ليست سوريا ليست اولويه لها
للاسف مثل هذه الذريعه اليوم ممكن للنظام
السوري وحلفائه ان يستخدمها مجددا لقصف
مناطق الشمال السوري وهي للاسف مناطق
مكتظه جدا جدا كثافه سكانيه عاليه لدينا
بين الاربع الى 5
ملايين انسان جزء كبير منهم نازحين بالاصل
اكثر من 50% ربما منهم نازحين اوضاع اصلا
انسانيه هشه بدون بنيه تحتيه الاشكال
حقيقه ان كان السيناريو كذلك دكتور محمد
ما مالات هذا القصف الذي يقوم به النظام
هو سيوصل باعتقادك الى ماذا ما ما
السيناريو اعتقد انه النظام يحاول ان يحشد
وهو يتمنى وعلى فكره كان هناك معلومات
سابقا انه النظام كان يضغط سابقا على
روسيا من اجل القيام بحمله كبيره على ادلب
لكن هناك توازنات هناك علاقات روسيه تركيه
وهناك ايضا انخراط روسيا في اوكرانيا كل
هذا عمليا منع روسيا من دعم النظام السوري
في ادلب لذلك انا اعتقد انه النظام يستطيع
ان يستمر بهذا القصف وهو قصف مؤذي جدا
ومتعب للمدنيين ويؤدي الى ضحايا لكن لا
اعتقد انه النظام وايران مع مع بعضهما
قادرين او قادران على فتح معركه جديده
تغير خطوط التماس اذا لم يتلقوا دعم روسيا
هل يتلقون دعما روسيا لمثل هذه الخطوه انا
لا اعتقد الان لان روسيا حاليا ليست بوارد
الدخول في توتر كبير في العلاقه مع روسيا
نحن نذكر في العام 2020 عندما توترت
العلاقات الروسيه وتركيه وكان هناك اشتباك
مباشر الجيش المجال ضيفنا السيد اندر
ايكوف سيد اندري ما مصير اتفاقات خفض
التصعيد في الشمال السوري هل روسيا
بوارد تغيير خطوط التماس كما قال الدكتور
محمد
سالم
انا لا يمكن ان اوافق بذلك 100% بسبب حتى
قبل هذا الحادث كان هناك قصف مستمر من قبل
الطيرات الروسيه ضد المجموعات الارهابيه
في نفس الوقت نحن قد شاهدنا بعض الجهود
الروسيه تجاه تركيا لتطبيع العلاقات بين
دمشق وانقره للاسف لم تؤدي هذه الجهود الى
نتائج بارزه ولكن على ما يبد روسيا لا
تتخلى عن هذه فكره وفي نفس الوقت على ما
يبدو الاهتمام الرئيسي بالنسبه لروسيا ليس
في في شمال سوريا ليس في ادلب ليس في في
هذا الدور التركي في شمال سوريا بل في دور
للولايات المتحده الامريكيه في سوريا بسبب
ان في نهايه المطاف الدور التخريبي دور
مشجع للتحركات الا الانفصاليه في صفوف
الاكراد من قبل الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه هو شيء خطير بالنسبه للجميع
بالنسبه لسوريا بالنسبه لروسيا بالنسبه لت
تركيا وبالنسبه لايران فلذلك على ما يبدو
ستكون هناك جهود الروسيه قبل كل شيء
دبلوماسيه لتوحيد صفوف تلك الدول الاربعه
المذكوره ضد ضد الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه
ولكن يعني ما ما مصير هذا التصعيد الذي
نشهده اليوم القصف المدفعي على مناطق
المعارضه السوريه ردا على استهداف الكليه
الحربيه في حمص الى اين يمكن ان
يفضي
هذا السؤال جيد في نهايه المطاف يعني
الامور قد تطورت بشكل مشابه في السابق كان
هناك تصعيد كان هناك نوع من التقدم للجيش
السوري كبير او صغير او لم يكن كان هناك
فقط تبادل النيران من قبل الطرفين في
نهايه المطاف كان هناك زياره او تواصل بين
الرئيس الروسي والرئيس التركي والامور قد
وصلت الى تهديه على ما يبدو نحن امام نفس
السيناريو يعني السؤال مطروح فقط حول حجم
هذا التصعيد هو سيكون كبيرا او صغيرا ولكن
في نهايه المطاف انا قلت الاهدف الرئيسي
بالنسبه لروسيا جيمز جفري هل من مصلحه
الولايات المتحده في هذه المرحله ان تعمل
على انهاء اتفاقات خفض التصعيد وتعيد خلط
الاوراق في الشمال
السوري اعتقد ذلك الواقع
هو انه منذ عام 2018 وحتى 2020 كان هناك
خفض التصعيد ووقف اطلاق النار بين
الولايات المتحده
والاتراك والنظام بحيث تجمد النزاع
بتغييرات صغيره على الارض وكان ذلك امر
جدا كان هناك خمسه جيوش خارجيه اسرائيل
وروسيا وايران والولايات المتحده وتركيا
كلها لها مشاركه في عمليات عسكريه وهناك
ثلاث ثلاث منظمات ارهابيه احرار الشام وبي
كي كي ووحدات حمايه الشعب السوري
والمعارضه كل هذا امر هذه تعتبر ساحه
معركه معقده جدا وان الاخطاء يمكن ان تحصل
فيها لهذا لبغي انيكون هناك انتباه شديد
من قبل الامم المتحده وكما احال بالنسبه
لاداره ترامب واوباما ان يكون هناك تواصل
وتفاهم بين الروس والامريكان بشكل مباشر
للسيطره على
ولكن الان الامور اختلفت سعاده السفير
جيمز جفري هناك اتهامات للولايات المتحده
ذكرها لنا السيد اندري اونت كوف انه ربما
يكون من مصلحتها اشغال روسيا على الساحه
السوريه رسائل ربما لبعض الدول العربيه
التي حااول ان تطبع مع النظام السوري
وكانت الولايات المتحده رافضه
لذلك ا مع
نعم زميلي الروسي صحيح حول تشتيت الانتباه
لكن هذا التشتيت لم يكن من قبل الولايات
المتحده من قبل الصين اللي اتخذت خطوات
عدوانيه جدا تتذكرون الطائره المسيره
الامريكيه تعرضت الى هجوم وهذا ادى الى
تصعيد امريكي و وقد ارسل طائرات الشبح
ستيلث الى سوريا وهذا هد الوضع ولكن لا
اعتقد مره اخرى لان كل هذه الامور تثير
القلق وقد تؤدي ال حد ولكن لا اعتقد انه
سيكون هناك اي تغيير كبير في الوضع العام
في سوريا الى ان يكون هناك فهم عام كامل
بين روسيا والولايات المتحده وبقيه
اللاعبين الاخرين شكرا لكم ضيوفنا من
واشنطن السفير جيمز جيفري المبعوث
الامريكي السابق الى سوريا من غازي عنتاب
الدكتور محمد سالم مدير وحده الدراسات في
مركزي ابعاد للدراسات الاستراتيجيه ومن
موسكو اندري ايكوف الكاتب والمحلل السياسي
شكرا لكم جميعا الى هنا مشاهدينا تنتهي
هذه الحلقه من برنامج ما وراء الخبر شكرا
لمتابعتكم الى
[موسيقى]
اللقاء